Katy Perry has found her prince charming  no goofy stop I won't date you gimme a  kiss  no not goofy the pop star and her  boyfriend  Orlando Bloom spent the day at Shanghai  Disneyland Park on Friday and she took  to Instagram to say this adorable pic of  the pair wearing matching Minnie and  Mickey Mouse socks writing when you find  your prince and if that isn't cute  enough the rise singer gave us a glimpse  into their entire day at the park via  her Instagram story like this and this  one and while shopping for Crystal  Castles Orlando recommended one in  particular but one of the best videos of  the day has to be when Orlando can be  heard rattling off trivia during the  Pirates of the Caribbean ride  this is not the first time the 31 year  old singer and 39 year old actor visited  one of the happiest places on earth they  were spotted at Disneyland California in  March